university was to support our community
colleges on a local level and they
certainly do need our support ok I would
like to introduce to you the moderator
of this panel Charles Chapman he is a
former Wall Street executive and a
friend of the fair Thank You Barbara our
panel today consists of four prominent
impassioned journalists who cover the
Middle East and the war on terror Chris
Hedges is no stranger to longtime
readers at the New York Times after
several years in the Middle East he went
to Sarajevo in 1995 his byline was a
staple of page one throughout the
bosnian tragedy later he was part of the
times team that received the Pulitzer
Prize for coverage of global terrorism
his book war is a force that gives us
meaning was a National Book Award
finalist his complete uncompromising an
utter condemnation of war has unsettled
more than a few commentators
co-authoring collateral damage is Layla
allari on a graduate of the Columbia
School of Journalism she has written for
UPI and Huffington Post her father is
sami al-arian former professor at the
university of south florida jane mayer
has been an investigative reporter for
over 20 years after stints at the
Washington star and the Wall Street
Journal she became a staff writer for
The New Yorker in 1995 her previous
books
zaman the second term of President
Reagan and the Clarence Thomas
nomination which he explores the topics
sorry which was a finalist for the
National Book Award her recent focus has
been the war on terror and particularly
the role of Vice President Cheney with
her new book the dark side she explores
the topics of anti-terrorism torture and
extreme rendition in chilling detail our
third book by Jonathan Mahler is a man
who has covered many topics in his
career while writing for The New York
Times Magazine his previous book ladies
and gentlemen the Bronx is burning was
adapted as a miniseries for ESPN perhaps
something to run when the sprockets ran
out on the famous Colts giants NFL
championship game his new book the
challenge hamden versus Rumsfeld and the
fight over the presidential power
examines the war on terror from a
high-profile case of Osama bin Laden's
driver will hear from each of the
authors in turn then there'll be
discussion and equestrian answer period
thank
well thank you very much I'm going to
speak just briefly about the Iraq war
the type of ward is and why it has
engendered such high numbers of civilian
casualties which of course propelled Al
and I into this seven-month
investigation where we interviewed 50
combat veterans from Iraq about civilian
atrocities that they either witnessed or
in several cases participated in Leila
is going to give you sort of the nuts
and bolts of how we did it how we broke
the book down and why we did it the way
we did I've spent 20 years of my life
overseas covering various conflicts
starting with the civil war in El
Salvador where I spent five years on to
the Middle East where I spend seven
years I was the Middle East bureau chief
for The New York Times and then as you
heard the Balkans of course in between
there were very few conflicts that I
missed from the Punjab to the civil war
in Algeria to the 1989 famine and war in
the Sudan Yemen the list goes on and on
and if you take war as a generic form I
think you can break it down into three
different types of conflicts all of
which I've covered one is the
essentially the civil wars that I
covered in Central America in the early
1980s these would be Nicaraguan fighting
Nicaraguan Salvadoran fighting
Salvadoran Guatemalan fighting
Guatemalan and then you have a what of
course they're becoming rarer and rarer
are set pieces between large mechanised
armies this is what I covered in the
first Gulf War and I'm not at all blind
to the severe loss of innocent civilian
life in southern Iraq because of the
saturation bombing indeed I was in the
uprising in Basra after the war until I
was captured by the Iraqi Republican
Guard I like to say I was embedded with
the Iraqi Republican Guard for eight
days and but that that took place in
essentially open desert were very few
civilians at least at
the moment that coalition forces moved
into Kuwait that that began there were
very few civilian casualties from that
clash and then you have what we have in
Iraq and that is essentially a colonial
occupation it is the imposition of a
foreign force coming in from the outside
and trying to impose its will by force
and these conflicts are always the
bloodiest and I think a engender highest
degree of civilian casualties because
when you have outside forces coming in
and I have seen this you know whether in
Gaza with the Israeli forces or in Iraq
with American forces they they're
culturally historically and
linguistically illiterate they the only
language they have to communicate with
those they are trying to subdue in
control is force and you are surrounded
by a hostile population and in fighting
an elusive enemy who you rarely see but
who can inflict very deadly casualties
whether through IEDs whether through
ambushes that are set up but that can
melt back into the population and robert
jay lifton when he studied the conflict
in Vietnam the great psychiatrist he
called these kinds of conflicts atrocity
producing situations and he argued that
in these kinds of conflicts where you
were battling an enemy a shadowy enemy
and remember that US soldiers and
Marines can go through an entire year of
occupation in Iraq and virtually never
see the people that are killing and
wounding comrades within their units
there becomes a very short psychological
leap between that hostile population and
the enemy itself until you carry out
attacks against unarmed innocence and no
longer make as a kind revenge attacks
and no longer make a distinction between
those civilians who are killed and the
enemy that you're fighting and this is
the conflict that we have now employed
in Iraq and and I would not hesitate to
say Afghan
stand and in these kinds of conflicts
essentially what you have is
indiscriminate use of heavy firepower I
mean I'm sure there's no they're
probably several people here who have
been in the military and and in some
ways you have to have been in the
military who have been in the conflicts
to understand how potent the weapons
being employed in densely populated
urban areas are saws these are light
7.62 machine gun belt fed machine guns
50 calibers automatic grenade launchers
these are not weapons that are designed
to be used where there is a large
civilian population in yet whether it's
convoys sort of charging these freight
trains of death moving down highways
whether its units laying down
suppressing fire after an IED goes off
these kinds of weapons and and they're
indiscriminate use in Iraq or a daily
occurrence for most Iraqis which is why
the numbers of Iraqi dead are are so
massive whether it's the lancet study at
600,000 latest at which was done 23
years ago and latest estimates run now
perhaps a million a million innocent
Iraqi dead and that kind of narrative
even for those of us opposing the war is
very difficult to accept and before I
turn it over to Leila I will say that
you know when we did this and and and
and she'll talk about how careful we
were about doing it but when we did it
it had exactly the reaction that took
place after winter soldier in 1981 when
Vietnam veterans came back John Kerry
made a cameo performance appearance in
this film and spoke honestly about
Vietnam and Detroit it caused a huge
sensation in Europe and was virtually
unseen and unheard here because it
defied that mythic narrative of our boys
and and and it was just too unpalatable
for Americans to digest in fact the
nation is publishing a year-long
investigative piece about a particular
operation that took place in Vietnam
where one of the people they quote said
we we did a meal I a month and that's
the reality of the ground
Iraq and when we published our peace was
it this is an expanded version of the
investigative piece we did fifteen
thousand words it was the whole issue of
the Nation magazine a year and a half
ago The Guardian newspaper in London
reprinted the entire fifteen thousand
words I mean almost unheard of for
foreign publication to pick up and
devote that much newspaper space
newspaper space to a report that was not
their own the independent was not far
behind BBC and yet here within the
United States with the exception of a
column by Bob Herbert it was virtually
ignored and I think for much the same
reason and now Leila will explain to you
what we did and why good afternoon well
as Chris mentioned the numbers are
staggering the latest figure of Iraqi
civilian casualties by British polling
agencies 1.2 million that means by the
end of two thousand and six five
thousand iraqis were being killed by US
forces a month now the Associated Press
in February 2007 asked Americans how
many Iraqis they think were killed since
the beginning of the war their answer
with 10,000 so you can see that there's
a huge gap between the reality and what
Americans think is happening in Iraq
part of that is the censorship that
Chris mentioned and in fact the story of
Iraqi civilian casualties made Project
Censored number one most censored story
in the media and in this I should say
that as far as I know this one figure of
1.2 million has never been reported in
the mainstream media and that was the
reason why we said about to do to report
and write collateral damage because we
wanted to know how Iraqis were being
killed what it is about the mechanics
and the day-to-day life in Iraq the
mechanics of the occupation in war that
results in the frequent killing and
daily abuse of civilians so what we did
was we contacted different veterans
organizations and we talked to 50 Iraq
war veterans men and women who served
there all over the country and we tape
recorded these interviews and for some
it was a cathartic experience but for
others it really took tremendous moral
courage to come forward and talk about
these incidents and we really did we
ended up dividing the book into four
major cat
gories of flashpoints of violence in
iraq the convoys that travel of speeds
of 60 miles an hour turning on the wrong
side of the road blocking roads running
ramming into iraqi vehicles going over
sidewalks and the reason these convoys
exist in are necessary is there the
arteries that sustain the occupation
there are vehicles of 20 to 30 that
drive in a row in sequence and they do
so for the protection of the US troops
at the expense of the Iraqi civilian so
what the troops told us is they were
told by their own commanders if an Iraqi
civilian disrupts the convoy they're
allowed to shoot and no questions will
be asked and sold her after soldier
marine after Marine told us that none of
these incidents that they witnessed or
participated in were investigated so
this figure of 1.2 million can even be
an underestimate considering how many
incidents happen that were never
reported I should also mention in
addition to these convoys patrols daily
patrols and neighborhoods before in
February 2007 they're about a thousand
patrols that went out into iraqi
neighborhoods now they're up to 5,000
when you have heavily armed soldiers who
are afraid for their own lives who
encounter roadside bombs and other
ambushes and other threats they're going
to respond with force and that's what
happens and what we were told is not
only are these incidents not reported
sometimes they're covered up so you have
so-called throw away guns which is in
the cases of some marines and soldiers
they carry extra ak-47s and bomb-making
materials that if they kill a
non-combatant and unarmed iraqi
sometimes they plan on the bodies of
these innocents and we heard of a story
of by a sergeant Patrick Campbell who
said he witnessed two snipers killing a
shooting 50 to 60 rounds into two Iraqi
men and he actually saw them planting
radios in the cars of these men and he
actually showed us the photographs of
them doing that so we know this happens
checkpoints similarly have this kind of
impunity where
the soldiers are told you know they told
us the common attitude was better to be
judged by 12 than carried by six meaning
they'd rather risk court-martial than
risk their own death in other words
better two killed and be killed and
that's the attitude that prevails and
for that reason a lot of times if an
iraqi accidentally passes a poorly
marked check mark would check point
which a lot of them are very poorly
marked we were told they're liable to be
shot and killed no questions asked and
Sergeant Dustin flat told us a story in
january 2005 in mosul of an elderly
iraqi couple driving through a
checkpoint and they it was very poorly
marked in his words he said some spooked
soldiers shot it up and the their
corpses lay there for three days and he
said we passed by them day after day and
finally the people in the town buried
the couple and we heard so many stories
like this raids are also a very common
occurrence in Iraq these patrols we
talked about the thousand patrols each
of them raids about 30 Iraqi homes a
night so you'd be hard-pressed to find a
single Iraqi family that hasn't
experienced a terror of a home raid
where soldiers break down doors they
separate the men from the women and
oftentimes arrest any military-age men
in the area and these stories that the
soldiers are coming back are haunting
them and they lot of them broke down as
they recounted these I finally we also
looked at the overall racism against
Arabs and Muslims in the military and
the fact that these acts of violence we
mentioned are made easier when there's a
prevailing attitude of racism the word
[ __ ] is commonly used to disparage and
denigrate Iraqis it's a word that
actually is a term of veneration in Arab
culture meaning someone who made the
pilgrimage to Mecca but it's now being
used as a slur in the military and what
the troops told us is it's used by the
highest commanders and it's actually
encouraged to dehumanize the Iraqis and
to make this type of abuse more
acceptable and what I want to say
finally is that occupation not only does
toys the people who are occupied it
destroys the occupiers and my fear is
that we still haven't come to terms of
the long-term effects and consequences
of this occupation so many of the
soldiers we talked to told us they had
thoughts of suicide in fact veterans of
Iraq and Afghanistan are two to four
times more likely to take their own
lives and veterans of other Wars so I
think in addition to doing the moral
thing of paying reparations to the Iraqi
people of coming to terms of the
devastation that we've caused in that
country we also have to acknowledge the
long-term effects on our own troops and
I just wanted to end with something that
was told to me by specialist josh
middleton of new york who told me he's
had thoughts of suicide since returning
and he said a lot of things really make
sense when you're doing them over there
but when you come back it's like how did
i do that it's just like a totally
different world everything is kind of
muted and I'm never really happy I don't
really enjoy things I just feel hopeless
and listless I don't fit in with other
kids my age it's really hard to relate
to anyone he said I want more than
anybody else to find a meaning to my
experience over there and something good
to feel about but I just can't find it
hi thanks very much for coming this
afternoon I'm in case the thought of
suicide is not dreary enough I'm here to
talk to you about torture so and about
how the United States in fighting terror
really violated its own values and and
what happened when that happened which
is my book is called the dark side and
it follows this history and the first
thing I wanted to say about the book is
that you know I think it's unlike some
some writers who probably feel great
about what they've written I think it's
a tremendous shame that I had to write
this book and it's it's it's not just a
shame because i sat at home for more
than a year in gained 10 pounds and also
got carpal tunnel syndrome and sort of
half paralyzed one side and began
talking so much about torture that my
family and friends were freaked out but
it's it's it's it's an incredible and a
terrible thing that that in the first
few years of the second millennium that
the United States would be able to have
a discussion about the pros and cons of
torture in a country that was founded on
the principles of the Enlightenment and
on the ideals that all people are
endowed by their creator with
inalienable rights and that among those
rights are protection from cruel and
unusual punishment and it's not just
people in America but all people because
we're human around the world and so
Thanks I hope that's for the words of
the founders um and then the question I
get a lot is you know what what's a nice
half Jewish girl like me writing a book
about torture for and the the way that I
got into this was that I am I began in a
small way like many obsessions by
writing stories for The New Yorker
magazine where I'm a staff writer and as
I began writing these pieces in
exploring kind of the underside of the
war on terror I began to get the sense
that this was not an ordinary subject
there was something incredibly profound
about it to me and it was not just about
how to keep America's security it wasn't
just a battle over security it was
becoming kind of a battle over the
country soul about our history our
values and where we draw the line in how
we treat detainees and I had to learn a
lot about the subject but when I did I
began to realize that we have a long
history in this country beginning with
George Washington of treating prisoners
of war in ways that are admirable and
that he's starting from the very
beginning this was done deliberately
because we were a new country in the new
world with new values and Washington in
particular wanted to make a point to the
British that we're going to try to do
things in in humane ways and he did it
for smart reasons not just for moral
reasons but also because he realized
that when you use cruelty it cuts into
military discipline and also becomes a
recruiting tool for the other side which
is what's happened with as we've seen
with in the war on terror the pictures
of things like Abu Ghraib and Guantanamo
or on every every al-qaeda site that's
that's to recruit young members so it
comes out to hurt us in the end and and
so I started in on doing some stories
for The New Yorker and realized that
with there was something very strange
going on and very upsetting and it began
in some ways with a piece I did where I
interviewed a man named ahora who is a
Canadian citizen who told me in
I think he talked to him in early two
thousand five he's an engineer that he
was changing planes in JFK Airport in
New York coming back from a family
holiday when he was pulled aside and
taken away by US officials he didn't
know who they were he was held for about
two weeks without being able to see a
lawyer and then he was put on a plane of
Gulfstream jet a really you know
incredibly sleek fancy one where they
showed movies on the way and he did not
know who that the officials were they
were speaking English he heard something
about special removal unit and he was
flown eventually to Syria where he spent
the next year of his life in a
subterranean cell that was about the
size of a grave where he was taken out
interrogated and beaten with electric
cables and he was there for more than a
year before his wife finally succeeded
in getting him out of there he was never
allowed to see a lawyer when he was
finally released the Syrians explained
that that he was he had never been a
terrorist as far as they were concerned
and they're not exactly soft on this
subject they mentioned that the United
States had asked for them to interrogate
him in this way and eventually he went
back to Canada and the Canadian
government did an inquiry and found that
he was cleared of all ties to terrorism
he was awarded 10 million dollars in
damages but in the United States he's
still on our terror watch list and you
cannot really get the story still of how
we got into this I've just heard that
they've reopened the investigation in
the Justice Department but we actually
have a law in this country that says you
can't deport someone to any country
where there's more than a 50-50 chance
that they might be tortured and Syria
appears on every list the State
Department has as a torture state so how
it was that this man who was innocent
got into this situation became of
interest to me it was right about that
time that but that President Bush said
we don't torture and we don't send
people to other countries to be tortured
so I started digging a little deeper and
discovered that that
happened to mehar r was actually part of
a program an organized very deliberate
program that had been authorized from
the very top of our government called
extraordinary rendition and that all
over the world these strange kidnappings
were taking place where people are being
snatched off the face of the earth they
were terror suspects and and being
disappeared without due process not
facing charges not facing trials just
plain being thrown into dungeons usually
in other countries where they use sort
of forms of interrogation that would be
illegal over here that was the beginning
of my inquiry it just became stranger
and stranger and kind of like putting
together this jigsaw puzzle where each
piece began to fit into something else I
began to talk to us officials about the
program there have been now about 125 or
more of such rendition since nine eleven
at least seven them according to the CIA
are being investigated as innocent
people who were renditioned no charges
have ever been brought against anyone
the officials that participate in this
program we're often wear black hoods no
one knows who they are there's no
accountability and what happened after
the Aurora case that was interesting was
we started there was a change in policy
where we stopped just sending these
kinds of suspects to other countries for
interrogation and we started taking them
ourselves into black site prisons around
the world which in some ways according
to people I've interviewed at the CIA
was even worse a bigger can of worms as
they were saying it because they had no
experience inside the CIA really of
running prisons they've done all kinds
of other things but they had not run
prisons and they don't have really much
experience in interrogation at that
point I began also trying to figure out
exactly what the program was for
interrogation in these black sites and
in Guantanamo the Abu Ghraib pictures
came out and as a reporter I was
fascinated by the fact that there seemed
to be the same kinds of things happening
all around the world where the US was
holding prisoners and I thought it
couldn't possibly be just coincidence
that there were people being hooded
shackled in the same way
subjected to incredibly strange sounds
everything from from cat food
commercials where there were like meow
meow sounds being played at them 24
hours a day two babies crying too
actually there was research done they
found Yoko Ono's singing was one of the
things that really breaks people down
I'm sorry if Yoko Ono hears this but
very effective apparently it's
psychological demolition they and it was
it was clear that that there was a
program of some sort or it seemed to be
you know we know we watched while people
were prosecuted at Abu Ghraib for doing
very similar things and we were told by
Rumsfeld than Secretary of State that
these were just a few bad apples at the
bottom of the barrel but but it seemed
to me too much of a coincidence that
there was the same thing going on all
around the world in Iraq and Cuba and so
I started looking into it and then
stumbled across what was actually a
curriculum it turned out there was like
a there is still a curriculum for
torture that the u.s. used and in the
most ironic way possible we got into
this which was it's it's something
called the seer program it's it's a
training program that the u.s. uses for
Special Forces mostly for and what it is
is a program where we subject our own
armed forces to the kind of torture that
they might possibly be subjected to if
they were taken prisoner by the most
immoral enemies in the world it was sort
of a Petry dish where they've studied
the kinds of torturers used in communist
countries particularly used to get
people to give false confessions
ironically and what while it had been
used always for defensive purposes
before nine eleven after nine eleven the
experts on the seer program in
particular psychologists became the
people who wrote out the program for
what we would do with our own prisoners
we wound up in other words copying the
methods of the you know the countries
that we labeled the evil empire and we
also used methods that had been used
specifically to get false confessions
out of people in communist countries and
unsurprisingly we wound up getting a lot
of false confessions out of people in
our own pro
some of which I also began to understand
led us into terrible false directions
including into the war in Iraq there's
one case about a man named even shake
al-libi that's that's just fascinating
because he was taken by the CIA sent to
Egypt where he was beaten up and I think
he was put in a tiny little dog cage for
about 80 hours and he wasn't sure he'd
ever get come out they kept asking him
about weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq it was right before the war and
they were looking for evidence and he
didn't know anything about weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq he was an
al-qaeda training person in Afghanistan
but he could see what they wanted so he
told him yeah their weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq and their
connections between al-qaeda and Saddam
Hussein it was just what the government
wanted to hear it was immediately piped
right into vice president Cheney's
office where an awful lot of this
program originated it made that
information made its way directly into
Colin Powell's speech at the UN which
was the speech in February 2003 that was
really the turning point in convincing I
think many people who were on the fence
that we had to go to war and almost
exactly a year later the same detainee
even sheikh al libi recanted there were
no weapons of mass destruction as the
911 Commission found in Iraq there were
very there were no serious connections
between Saddam Hussein and al-qaeda they
asked this man well why did you tell us
this and he said I had to say something
they were killing me so you can
definitely I've talked to an awful lot
of people about this subject and if you
talk to experts unlike the amateurs at
the CIA if you talk to people at the FBI
for instance who have interrogated
people for years they'll tell you you
can pummel people into saying almost
anything but getting the truth is a
really different issue and we've managed
to get a lot of that information out of
this program in fact somebody who is a
very very senior person at the CIA told
me ninety percent of what we've gotten
is crap so it's been at a very high
price I think and I could go on and on I
don't want to but I did want to end by
saying that that while it's a shame to
have to
a book like this on the other hand I
think it's a tremendous privilege to be
able to be in a country where you can
write about such terrible things and
have an open debate about it and have an
election like the last election and I
wanted to close by reading just a tiny
fragment of a peat of a bit from hannah
arendt from her book Eichmann in
Jerusalem I don't view what the US did
as equivalent by any means I don't mean
to say that we are the Third Reich this
is not on that scale at all it is a
violation of many of our ideals but let
me but it's not at that level but I
wanted to read what she said which was
that that the goals of police states are
to create holes of oblivion into which
all deeds good and evil disappear so
that is and she says that the job of
writers their duty is to rescue that
history to send into those holes and
recount especially the individual acts
of heroism so that they can be told to
our children and passed on and what I
tried to do in this book was not just
write about what went wrong but I wanted
to write a lot about their an awful lot
of heroes who stood up to this program
and they are people of all political
points of view there are a lot of
conservative lawyers there are people in
the FBI there are a lot of soldiers top
level people including the top lawyer at
the Navy Alberto Mora who is a
cuban-american who said we're not were
better than this we are not going in
that direction and so as our what a rent
was saying was that that we need to pass
the stories on of the people who have
stood up in this way she says it's
beyond expectation that everyone will be
a hero or was this tyranny but it's
enough humanly speaking for the planet
to remain a place fit for human habitat
that if you would stand up and so I
wanted to tell their story in this book
thank you all for being here that's
actually a very apt introduction for for
my comments because my book is actually
about two of these heroes who emerged
from this and like Jane's book it grew
out of magazine work in my case at the
new york times magazine and it began
with with a story i wrote back in the
spring of 2004 and it was a profile of a
naval officer who was also a Jag lawyer
lieutenant commander Lieutenant
Commander charles Swift was his name and
i was sent down to Washington to spend
some time with him and to profile him
because he had just been essentially
plucked from anonymity in the Jag Corps
and assigned to a new unit at the
Pentagon that had been created to serve
as the defense team for the first
defendants to be tried in military
tribunals in America since World War two
so these were going to be these historic
military tribunals we're going to try
certain authorized by the president we
were going to where we were going to try
certain enemy combatants in the war on
terror and of course they needed lawyers
to defend these guys and they reached
out to the Jag Corps and and chose this
this man lieutenant commander Charles
Swift to be one of the lawyers and the
time I met him he'd actually just been
assigned a client and his client was
named Salim Hamdan and homme Don was a
driver had admitted to being a driver
for Osama bin Laden now when I embarked
on this story my assumption and really
the public's assumption was that that
that Swift as a Navy officer would
essentially do what the government
wanted him to do and as Swift put it to
me at the time to roll over and have my
belly scratched now the government was
what the government wanted Swift to do
was essentially tell his client Tom Don
to plead guilty to appear at this
military tribunal and plead and plead
guilty so that was was what the
government was was assuming would happen
in fact they were so confident that it
would happen that when they assigned
Swift to represent hond on the letter
his detailing letter appointing him to
represent homme Don told him that he
could meet with his client under the
condition that he
was negotiating a guilty plea so the
deck was was was stacked against him
from the start now it quickly became
clear to me that that this was not
Swift's intention at all not only was
Swift planning to defend hommed on on
the facts of the case which is to say he
was going to argue that yes he was a
driver for Osama bin Laden but that he
was in no way involved in the al-qaeda
conspiracy had no had no knowledge or or
or hadn't participated in any of what in
any way in any any of the activities of
al-qaeda in fact he was basically just
an uneducated Yemeni who found his way
there and was working there so he was
not only going to make that argument he
was going to go a big step further he
was actually going to sue the Bush
administration who was going to sue his
commander-in-chief on behalf of this guy
arguing that this very system these
military tribunals this very system that
his client was to be tried in was
illegal and to do that now Swift was was
a great trial lawyer and the Jag Corps
had spent many years defending wayward
servicemen of all sorts of petty crimes
but he was by no means a constitutional
lawyer so so to do that he recruited a
young Indian American law professor at
Georgetown University named Neil katja
and together they represented hommed on
now my story was published in this first
story was published back in in June as
it was in 2004 and the headline of the
story was commander Swift objects and I
realized at that point that that I
really was was at the beginning of what
could prove to be an interesting story
so I started continuing to follow it
wrote some more stories about it and
began working on this book and well what
what sort of quickly emerged or
gradually emerged I guess I would say is
is that there were sort of two separate
narrative threads and one was the story
of Swift and hummed on and just to tell
you a little bit more about Han dong he
was a man who had had grown up in a
tribal region of Yemen in southeastern
Yemen very poor his parents were farmers
and died at a very when he was very
young he was 11 when his parents died so
he was orphaned and
and he sort of drifted around drifted
around Yemen had to had the equivalent
of about a fourth grade education and
ultimately kind of in his early 20s
found his way to the capital city in
Yemen sana where he thought he might
have a better chance at finding a job
but he was uneducated and and so instead
he found himself sort of driving a taxi
part-time and sleeping on a dirty
mattress in a crowded boarding house and
he was there recruited for jihad and
eventually kind of made his way to bin
laden with a group of other jihadis in
1996 and worked for bin Laden for a
number of years as I said as a driver
there's there's no evidence and not even
the government has argued that he ever
was was anything more than that but in
the aftermath of 911 he was of course
captured and and kept in Afghanistan in
a couple of different prisons
interrogated dozens of times over the
course of about brutally interrogated in
certain cases over the course of about
six months before being sent to
Guantanamo Bay where he was for about
another year and a half several months
of which he spent in solitary
confinement before into his cell one day
walks a man in a military uniform saying
my name is lieutenant commander Charles
Swift and I'm here to help you so thus
begins this really extraordinary
relationship between a graduate of the
u.s. Naval Academy a life-long officer
of the US Navy and and navy lawyer and a
suspected terrorist and Swift would
dutifully go down to guantanamo every
month and spend several days with han
dong when Homme Don would agree to see
him because often homme Don would would
refuse to allow him in a Cell would
refuse to talk to him and because homme
Don was was spent so much time in
solitary confinement he really had no
one known to vent to no one to blame
except Swift so so he was at times very
nasty to Swift and he fired him on
numerous occasions but Swift had to had
to hang in there and even after being
fired he would go back down and and and
try to get Tom Don to speak with him and
and ultimately harm done always would
though with some
times require several separate trips and
and of course the other challenge that
that Han dong that Swift was facing with
hommed on was that Han don was was of
course the despairing was constantly
losing hope about that he was ever going
to get off of Guantanamo Bay and and he
went on numerous hunger strikes at one
point had to be force-fed in a
restraining chair and and again it was
Swift who had to go down there and
convince him that that he had to keep
himself alive that he had to hold out
hope that someday he would return to
Yemen and see his family and so it
really was was a remarkable relationship
and they became very close over the
years so in the book I sort of tracked
that relationship and I also go into
detail about the legal case which is
sort of the second narrative story here
and that story begins with the lawsuit
that they filed in 2004 and the lawsuit
known as Tom Don versus Rumsfeld and it
argued essentially that these military
tribunals were illegal and they were
illegal for a couple of different
reasons the first being that President
Bush had unilaterally authorized them in
the aftermath of 9-11 he had issued a
military order saying we are going to
I'm authorizing the Pentagon to create
these trials to write the rules for the
trials the procedures there will be no
appeals to any federal courts in other
words the federal courts will have no
oversight over this Congress will have
no oversight over this so so the first
the first sort of arm of their lawsuit
argued that that that's illegal the
President does not have the power to do
that and furthermore the lawsuit went on
to argue that essentially the rules of
these trials were unfair and they were
unfair because they failed to live up to
guarantees provided by the Geneva
Conventions in a body of law known as
the Uniform Code of Military Justice so
they filed their lawsuit and and to just
give you some sense of how unlikely it
seemed when they first filed the lawsuit
at the time the Bush administration was
arguing and to great effect in the
federal court system that the federal
courts actually had no right to hear
cases from Guantanamo Bay and indeed
that's that's the reason why the
government
chose one tanem obey because not because
it's you know warm and sunny but because
they believed that it was outside the
jurisdiction of the federal courts so
this was the first obstacle they were up
against they were able to clear that
obstacle and their lawsuit did get
traction and I follow it as it sort of
proceeds through the federal court
system and they actually won a huge
victory at the at the lower court at the
federal court and a judge a federal
judge a district judge in Washington DC
halted the pre-trial hearings of the
military tribunals as as they were going
on on Guantanamo Bay i was on guantanamo
bay when a when a when when the judge
indefinitely halted the proceedings
because because a federal judge had told
the president they were illegal well as
it turned out they lost the case at the
court of appeals and then it their last
resort of course was the supreme court
and to give you a sense of how unlikely
getting a hearing of the supreme court
was the the supreme court gets on the
order of about eight thousand petitions
for review a year and they hear about
100 cases so the numbers alone were
daunting but the Supreme Court is
historically especially wary of hearing
cases that involve having to weigh in on
what kind of the press what kind of
power the president has to keep the
country safe during times of armed
conflict so there was every reason to
believe they weren't going to get a
hearing at all as it turned out they did
after months of deliberation months of
arguments internal arguments inside the
Supreme Court the justices a majority of
the justices decided that they would
hear the case and now of course the
question became well who's going to
argue it because there's there's a
eighty percent of the arguments
delivered at the Supreme Court are given
by lawyers advocates who have argued at
least a dozen cases at the court there's
a there's a group of Supreme Court
advocates who do this for a living but
the young georgetown law professor who
was was 35 years old at the time and i
mentioned want it to be the one to argue
the case himself he had devoted at this
point several several years of his life
to it around the clock and he didn't
want to let the argument go and so over
over the the objections of
virtually everyone whom he spoke to
every every Supreme Court advisor
everyone inside and outside their legal
team he insisted that he was going to
argue this case and so he felt that the
only way he could do that was was to
just prepare obsessively and so what he
did is he took out a legal pad and he
wrote down the names of the 15 lawyers
and law professors around the country
who most intimidated him now this was a
young man who graduated at the very top
of his class at Yale Law School had had
clerked on the Supreme Court for Justice
Breyer and and it was now a law
professor at this esteemed Law School
Georgetown and yet he had his list of 15
lawyers and law professors and he called
each and every one of these lawyers and
law professors and asked them if they
would moot him if they would grill him
and he flew all around the country and
did dozens of moot courts in front of
these judge these mock judges to prepare
for the argument he also kept a copy of
the entire case record hundreds and
hundreds of pages next to his bed and
before he fell asleep at night he would
study the entire case record because he
wanted to commit the entire thing to
memory in the event that during the
argument if one of the justices said oh
well mr. katiyal where where can I find
this charge that you're referring to he
wanted to be able to not cite merely the
page but the specific paragraph on that
page with from memory and as it turned
out this actually happened during the
argument justice Stevens asked him where
he could find something and he directed
him to that very paragraph on the very
page so the other thing the last thing
I'll mentioned that he did was he knew
he was aware that he was a little stiff
he was a law professor he had very he
had no courtroom experience he had it
argued three cases in his life one of
which was a traffic ticket another was a
landlord-tenant dispute in law school so
he knew he had to work on his on his
presentation so he agreed to work with a
touchy feely trial consultant who had
him line up all of his sons stuffed
animals and practice making eye contact
with them as if they were the justices
and he also told him he insisted that on
the morning of the argument he get up
early
and in the shower he's sing and he's
seeing in a full voice so that when he
found himself standing before the
justices the sound of his own voice
didn't make him self-conscious well as
it turned out he didn't want to wake his
wife up on the morning of the argument
so he didn't sing in the shower he
realized that he had forgotten to do so
so 15 minutes before the argument began
he ducked into the bathroom of the
lawyers lounge at the Supreme Court and
belted out the words to the only song
that he could think of the lyrics for
which happened to me mister rogers
neighborhood he then proceeded to
deliver what what experts agree is is
really one of the greatest Supreme Court
arguments of that term and they won the
case and they they didn't win just a
narrow victory often the Supreme Court
likes to decide cases very narrowly they
don't want to make sweeping sweeping
judgments if they can avoid it but this
was a sweeping judgment and what this
judgment said was not only that these
military tribunals were illegal and that
if the President did indeed want to do
them he could not do it without the
cooperation and input from Congress
without legislation from Congress but
the court went a step further the court
also said that the President does not
have the authority to violate the laws
and treaties of the United States even
during wartime now that may sound
self-evident but as Jane was saying
before the the Bush administration many
of the Bush administration's policies in
the war on terror were built on this
assumption as it turned out false
assumption that the president could even
could if he felt necessary during a time
of war violate the laws and treaties of
the United States so that's what gave us
programs like the the extraordinary
rendition program that Jane was talking
about it's also what what led to the
secret surveillance program the
warrantless wiretapping so needless to
say this decision the home Don decision
created a great panic inside the Bush
administration and it also necessitated
legislation on these military tribunals
well Congress and the president went
back and forth and and eventually came
to some sort of agreement and new trial
rules were drawn up were passed into law
many people still
leave that they are inadequate but
nevertheless after after seven years in
American custody hamadan went on trial
last summer and a jury of military
officers heard his case acquitted him
all together on the most serious charge
brought against him and the government
was asking that the government that that
this panel of military officer sentenced
him to somewhere between 30 years and
life in prison as it turned out this
panel of military officers decided he
should be sentenced to after time served
five months so hon don is scheduled to
be released now at the end of December
and the last thing I'll say and it's a
it's I will end on a similar note to
Jane is that you know there's there's
been a great deal of criticism of the
Bush administration's policies in the
war on terror and we've heard a lot of
them here on this panel and and and many
of them are certainly justified but but
actually what that's not the story I
tell in this book that's not what this
book is about to me this book is
actually about really the greatness of
this country and the fact that these two
men one a Navy officer another a child
of immigrants could could bring a
lawsuit against the the commander in
chief the president the united states
have that lawsuit heard in the highest
court in the country and win and change
the course of history in doing so to me
actually says great things about the
resilience of American values and the
resilience of our Constitution and the
durability of our Constitution
in one last one last thing I'll say
which is that that that it's actually
lieutenant commander Swift put it put it
better than I can when he said in most
countries when a military officer
challenges his commander-in-chief it's
called a coup in the United States it's
called hamden V Rumsfeld
now comes time for questions and
discussion and while the questioners are
lining up I have something that I would
like to start them off with which is the
question of where do we go from here how
do we unwind certain aspects of the
bureaucratic military and legal cultures
that have sprung up albeit they're very
recent growth but they still take hold
and they're going to have to be unwound
I'd like to know where do we go from
here how is it going to be done how can
the new administration do anything
bureaucracies don't turn on a dime are
yes let let me start with the wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq because when you
look closely at the foreign policy of
the Republican and the Democratic
parties there really isn't a lot of
difference both John McCain and Barack
Obama have called for call during the
campaign for an extension of the war in
Afghanistan which i think is a
disastrous mistake one once wonders if
they've read anything about the 10-year
Soviet effort to subdue Afghanistan a
hundred thousand Red Army soldiers
fifteen thousand dead or go back and
look at the disastrous attempts by the
British to control Afghanistan in the
19th century it is not a country that
culturally or geographically has lent
ever let itself to foreign occupation
and I think we've seen in the last seven
years a disastrous slippage the Taliban
when we went into Afghanistan controlled
seventy-five percent of the country they
today control half of Afghanistan most
Westerners can't go outside of the city
limits places like Kandahar and as the
Afghan
Taliban has become resurgent there has
been by the way of correlating
resurgence of the poppy trade of the
heroin trade which the Taliban provides
security protection for the poppy
growers imposes war taxes and this funds
the insurgency and you just saw the
other day another wedding party was
destroyed by aerial bombing because it's
a vast country because much of it is
remote because there is a resurgent
Taliban we are resorting more and more
to air power which is probably the most
potent recruiting weapon the Taliban has
in terms of Iraq there's a kind of
Barack Obama has proposed a kind of
downsizing and removal of some combat
brigades which he I think disastrously
would like to transfer to Afghanistan
but he wants to retain American control
of the airport of our Imperial City in
the center of Baghdad the green zone and
of the three super bases he wants to
leave anyone's guess is between 50 and
60 thousand troops behind to Train Iraqi
soldiers and these are his words to
fight terrorism I think that for those
of us who have spent as long as I have
in the Middle East there are two
components one you know that the
imposition of force is doomed to failure
the decline in violence that we see in
Iraq is not due to the surge it's due to
the fact that there are a hundred
thousand Sunni insurgents are now
receive monthly salaries of three
hundred dollars a month from US
taxpayers not to kill American soldiers
and we don't own these people we only
rent them we tried the same thing with
tribal groups in the Taliban and when
they got enough money in weapons they
went right backs into the arms of the
Taliban so I think it's important for us
to be very clear-headed that the the
codification by the bush administration
of these illegal wars of aggression and
under post nuremberg laws these are
criminal wars of aggression we have no
right under international law to debate
the terms of the occupation and my fear
is that that codification of illegal
prion
war is something that is going to be
carried over with disastrous
consequences for us in the Middle East
and ultimately disastrous consequences
for the Obama administration itself and
one hopes that there is a kind of
realization we you know I think there
would be a tragic a tragic tragic result
of this misguided policy would be that
Obama sort of ends up like LBJ you know
at one time sort of wanting the Great
Society and being sucked down by the
maratha of Vietnam so I think it's
important for those of us who you know
realize that that we ultimately are
faced with only two options in Iraq and
Afghanistan and that is an orderly or
phased and phased withdrawal or a
collapse of the mission to begin to
agitate as hard as we can for a total
withdrawal of American troops from Iraq
and Afghanistan
in in terms of the some of the other
legal policies in the war on terror I
feel worried at a turning point where we
don't necessarily know how it's going to
come out so maybe I'm a little less less
optimistic than Jonathan in there going
to be some serious problems to work out
down in Guantanamo you've got cases
you've got people down there who have
been taken outside of the rule of law
where you really can't very easily bring
them back inside the rule of law
specifically you've got people like that
Mohammed Al Qahtani who was supposed to
be the 20th hijacker who was tortured
for months on end they recently had to
drop charges against him because any
defense lawyer representing him would be
able to say he'd been tortured and it's
it's there's a the transcript of his
interrogation ran in Time magazine and
you've read it and you know that he's
got the kind of defense that would get
him off and yet he is supposed to be the
20th hijacker so what do you do with a
case like that it just illustrates how
much those shortcuts that they took have
ended up hurting the country's ability
to really win the war on terror which
they really have to do I think by
winning the hearts and minds of the next
generation of young Muslims and you
can't really do that by torturing
people's relatives so I it's I think
it's going to be a tough question it's
also a tough question about what the
American public wants to happen in terms
of accountability for the war crimes
that were committed over the last seven
years they're definitely any not a
lawyer but any lawyer you talk to who
understands this area will say there's
been a lot of war crimes committed and
you know do we want to hold the public
officials accountable for this or do we
want to let them off you know it's it's
it's it it's a tough it's a tough issue
and I think it's going to rest in all of
your laps it all depends what the public
wants really and asks for yeah I mean I
would just add to that that I think
you're actually right about Guantanamo I
mean you know president-elect Obama is
already of course talking about is his
intention to close Guantanamo but it's
going to be very complicated because
there are a number of people there who
whom he is not going to want to release
who are going to be very different he's
not going to do these military tribunals
and they're going to be virtually
impossible to try in federal courts so
what can he do he has two options
neither of which are great neither which
are popular one is to create these new
special national security courts which
will have those same issues of
legitimacy as these military tribunals
this sort of made up legal system and
the other would be to go to Congress and
ask for some sort of new legislation
allowing him to continue to detain
people and that that too is is of course
you know to the dubious proposition so
so you know you're right i mean
Guantanamo is going to be going to be
very difficult issue for him as for the
question of accountability I think you
know I think Jane is right and I think
the question is is really going to be
one for Congress that I think that that
you know we saw unfortunately during the
bush years that the Congress wasn't
willing to stand up to the president
wasn't willing to perform its
constitutional obligation to provide
vigorous oversight of the executive
branch and to investigate to issue
subpoenas when necessary to do what
needs to be done and and I think we have
to hope that that the the new Congress
will will will want to take this on will
want there are already some
investigations going I know the the seer
program that Jane talked about a little
earlier senator Levin of Michigan is in
the midst of a serious investigation
into that and we have to hope that there
will be more and that they will be that
they will be serious and and that you
know the truth is that the sort of a
difficult situation that we're in right
now in two wars and in a financial
crisis won't prevent Congress from from
from making sure that they get to the
bottom of everything that went on
because it's going to be critical for
the historical record as far as a iraq
war I just want to say very quickly
where to go from here the Iraqi refugee
crisis is definitely something that will
take years and years to resolve it's the
largest refugee population in the world
now and at five million and I think we
as a country have fallen short as far as
doing our part in giving these refugees
a new home after creating the situation
they're in now
yeah waited long enough for your busty
please there were two documentaries film
documentaries that have come out in the
last year or so one was Earl Morris's
SOP about other gray any other was Alex
didn't forget last name give me
something taxi to the dark side now and
then of course there are several films
that that were a non-fiction although
based on reality none of them were seen
by too many Americans now what I'm
getting at is is there any hope that
there's going to be a significant change
an attitude to the American of the
American public so they can give the
kind of momentum that will be necessary
of Congress or the new attorney general
is willing to open up this great can of
worms because it's going to be very very
difficult to do and unless you have
substantial American support from the
populace I don't see how will happen
miss bear do you have any thoughts on
that well I don't I have to say as a
political reporter I don't see a ground
swell of interest in moving in that
direction I think if anything people are
in a mood to move on and and maybe you
know sweep these things under the rug if
anything it's interesting the place
where there might be action you know
things percolating legally against our
own officials is actually elsewhere in
the world the the in Britain recently a
criminal investigation was opened up
into the CIA's treatment of a British
citizen who was renditioned to Morocco
among other places and the rest of the
world is more inflamed about this than
then maybe we are here at home next
question
um yes I've heard a lot today and it
would appear as though we have leaders
that are murderers and thieves and it
has gotten very well absorbed by all of
our systems and the question is really
what does that say about us as a people
American citizens and what is it that
American citizens what can we do besides
vote to really try to get this thing
under control just in your opinions well
you know I think the problem is that we
who care about maintaining the open
society no longer have moral imperatives
that cannot be crossed and and and
because of that the Democratic Party I
think in many ways is as much to blame
for the deterioration of the rule of law
and democratic values as the Republican
Party you know the passage of FISA which
for those of us who communicate
frequently in the middle with the Middle
East is disastrous the FISA Reform Act
which Barack Obama by the way voted for
squelches the some 30 lawsuits and lower
courts that we're working their way up
that would have challenged the
telecommunications companies of course
the communication companies Pumped
anywhere from 10 to 15 million dollars
into lobbying efforts to make sure that
the they were granted immunity and the
Bush administration retro actively
illegal activities carried out by the
Bush administration were made legal you
know the list goes on and on the fact
that Democrats were elected in 2006 to
stop the war and then never continued to
fund not only continue to fund the war
but actually supported troop increases
in Iraq so I think that you know we we
have to begin to make the Democratic
Party if you're a Democrat or a
Republican Party was interesting on the
bailout because some of the most
eloquent responses especially in the
house came from the
look inside of the house but I think we
as voters begin to have to begin to have
moral imperatives and and we have to be
willing to step outside the two-party
system when those moral imperatives are
challenged well we heard a number of
extraordinary stories today including
extraordinary rendition and I think we
have to look back at this extraordinary
two-year presidential campaign that
didn't mention any of these stories and
take a look at us and I think thanks for
what you just said mr. hedges because
unless we take extraordinary steps to
find some ten or fifteen or twenty or
twenty-five percent of our lives to make
this happen if we just go back home and
sit and watch on the tube I don't think
any of its going to change we need to
give it that impaired I want to know how
you feel about it you already started to
say that I wonder how the others feel
about that what we can do well you can
buy books about it no I mean I think
that you can show no I mean I honestly
think that you know you you're right i
mean it didn't it was it was absent from
absent from the campaign was was
discussion of these issues absent from
the campaign was discussion of the whole
issue of presidential power and the
abuse of presidential power during the
bush administration and you know i think
you know all all we can do is in all you
can do and as and all of us can do this
as part of the public is to just to be
engaged on these issues and to ask
questions and to demand answers and I
think you know again I would go back to
Congress I mean I think people have to
have to insist that that their
congressman there you know that they
don't let this stuff go and you know
that's that and then we have to let the
system handle the rest I mean let me
just say it wasn't absent from the
campaign it was raised by candidates
like Dennis Kucinich cynthia mckinney
ralph nader but these candidates were
denied a voice by a corporatized media
that did not want
these issues discussed whether it was
extraordinary rendition or the offshore
penal colonies we run where we openly
torture human beings who are stripped of
legal rights whether it's universal
single-payer not-for-profit health care
whether it's the bailout which a
hundred-to-one constituents did not want
and they passed anyway because the
financial service sectors did want it
the issues were raised but I think we
have to seriously begin to examine to
what extent this two-party duopoly
essentially shut those discussions out I
mean in in the debates in New Hampshire
Tim Russert asked all of the Democratic
candidates if any of them could
guarantee that we would be out of Iraq
by 2012 and nobody including John
Edwards would make that guarantee and
the one Democratic candidate who was
willing to make that guarantee Kucinich
was standing outside of the snow bank
with his protesters because he'd been
locked out of the debate and I think
that when we shut down that debate I'm
you know be frank with you I voted for
Nader when we shut down that debate we
diminish ourselves as a democracy and we
have to begin to find a new militancy
because what we are undergoing through
our shadow corporate government is a
kind of coup d'etat in slow motion
okay as the as the voice of corporatized
media at The New Yorker magazine owned
by the advance company I actually think
that that some of the so-called
mainstream media have done an amazing
job reporting on the subject that I've
been reporting on you've got the
Washington Post breaking story after
story with danna priests and other
people about the black sites you got the
New York Times which you would never
have known about the the wiretapping
story if not for James risen at the new
york times there have been some great
mainstream media reporters and editors
standing up to a very intimidating
government at some points and i also
think that you know that i mean it was
it was in least in the area of torture
it was again tim russert who did in fact
ask the candidates about where they
stood on that and part of the reason
there was not a debate which was amazing
to me watching this was because both of
the nomination nominees of their parties
both McCain and Obama have spoken out
very forcefully against torture so they
didn't even have a difference on this
subject they were both very much in a
different place from bush which i think
is good news I mean and there's a lot
still there's a long way to go you could
look at it as half empty or half full
but I think there's a lot to be
optimistic amount about compared to
where we were when i started covering
this stuff for years ago five years ago
so that's right none of we would know
about any of these scandals without the
media really i mean the bush
administration deliberately obscure
protected this information the same way
that they you know kept it from congress
they kept it from the media and and yet
the mainstream media that corporatized
media i think did an extraordinary job i
mean again the warrantless wiretapping
story today we may still not know about
a secret surveillance program going on
in the united states were it not for the
reporting of the new york time so I yeah
I don't think we can blame the media for
this at all but can I add one thing
which is again about why it's rests back
in your laps is because I talked to
chuck schumer at one point who the
senator from New York and said then why
aren't you speaking up or about torture
and civil liberties and he said my
constituents don't care
about it so if if they feel their
constituents don't care they are going
to be spineless yes next please thank
you all of you for your vital and
necessary work the question I have is a
forward-looking one there's been some
support as you could gather from Desmond
Tutu and Nelson Mandela for the new
president which made me think of the
truth and reconciliation Commission's of
South Africa how vital do you think or
how valid do you think those are as a
model going forward perhaps in Lansing
this boil and coming up with solutions
for the future well the model that I
think of is is you know the Church
Committee post post-watergate post Nixon
I mean to me that's you know that that's
what needs to happen now we need to have
an incredibly aggressive congressional
investigation that you know will lead
wherever it leads but but it needs to
you know in the problem is that it's
going to be you know these claims of
executive privilege are going to become
very sticky and they're going to be lots
of long difficult legal battles over
what what information the administration
what will be the former administration
will be compelled to turn over and
certainly the the Congress has made that
more difficult by passing that FISA bill
which granted retroactive immunity to
all the telecom executives who won't
have to tell what we'll never know who
whose phones were tapped and why and
what that what was done with that
information because because of the FISA
bill so nevertheless I mean to me that's
that's the model that that I think about
that that's sort of just sort of
sweeping you know hundreds and hundreds
of interviews in subpoenas and you know
everything that that sort of needed to
be done to find out exactly what who
ordered what when and if there is you
know if someone is subject to
prosecution then prosecute them I mean I
think there's you know it's obvious
there's political peril for Obama in
pushing for prosecutions he doesn't want
to look like he's
on a partisan witch hunt and looking
backwards with all the problems they've
got now but I got to say at the same
time you know and I can understand that
I'm somewhat torn on this myself because
I've interviewed people at the CIA who
said to me they personally refuse to get
involved in this program because they
thought it was a slippery slope and it
was going to end up with hearings in
front of Congress and people going to
jail so if nobody does go to jail and
there are no hearings in front of
Congress where's the deterrent that's
right you you basically are ya your
earring you're incentivizing if the
argument that the president is basically
allowed during wartime to do whatever he
needs to do is allowed to if there are
no prosecutions and then then you're
this be incentivizing future presidents
to do the exact same thing and to say
well you know we have a precedent for
this I I was doing it in the interest of
national security and and and that's
that so so that's right I think that's
the danger obviously if not of not
taking this a step further thank you
ladies and gentlemen very much that
concludes our program the authors will
be signing copies of their books in the
designated area
you